et nous recevons ce matin olivier abel
bonjour bonjour merci d'être avec nous
vous êtes philosophe et professeur
d'éthique à l'institut protestant de
théologie de montpellier dans votre
livre de l'humiliation qui est jusqu'ici
le nouveau poison de notre société vous
nous expliquer pourquoi et c'est ce que
l'on va voir aussi entre autres
ensembles nous avons tendance dans notre
société a nié l'existence de
l'humiliation et vous propose également
des pistes pour qu'il y ait moins
d'humiliation dans notre société mais
d'abord j'aimerais revenir sur les
résultats de la présidentielle française
dimanche emmanuel macron a été réélu
avec 58 5% des voix marine le pen elle
obtenu 41 4% c'est un score historique
puisqu'elle a gagné près de 8 points par
rapport à 2010 est elle a permis à
l'extrême noir de franchir ce fameux
cette fameuse barre des 40% comment
est-ce que vous analysez ces résultats
est ce que c'est finalement une partie
de la population qui se sentant si on en
vient à l'humiliation se sentant trop
humilié par la gauche par la droite par
le centre et bien fini petit à petit et
bien par se faire entendre oui mais si
on mais je pense que l'humiliation
n'explique pas tout évidemment
mais y contribue inlassablement c'est un
voilà c'est quelque chose qui était
d'une hypothèse qui ne qui n'est pas
assez travaillé gérer compris avec
considération je pense qu il ya dans le
monde entier on a vu l'élection de train
pas aux états unis s'est parlé dans wii
c'est alors on a beaucoup analysé comme
voilà un peu la revanche des classes qui
entraîne du média l'histoire craintes de
se déclasser et c'est un bon laisser ces
petits blancs qui perdent un petit peu
le sens des repères de la grandeur de
l'amérique à quetta et dire voilà on a
trié manque en france aussi ça ressemble
beaucoup à ce genre de choses et donc je
me dis pourquoi faudrait analyser plus
finement qu'est ce que c'est une des une
des hypothèses justement que j'explore
j'ai essayé c'est l'idée que ce qui est
au pouvoir actuellement avec avec les
maquereaux mais aussi toute une série
tout un tout une toute une classe
sociale qui est inc et active qui est
créative qui est créatrice qui est
nos ventes étaient assez justement
l'idole de l'émancipation de l'une des
deux celui qui est libre et autonome qui
est flexible qui peut beaucoup de
connexions qui a un grand carnet d
adresse et il ya beaucoup de gens qui
sont de plus en plus gérer coincé dans
une province avec peu de peu de lien
donc sentiments de fidélité sentiment de
d'être d'être accroché à 10 ans avec
voile avait eu un peu de moyens et état
je pense que cette fracture elle
augmente et que justement voilà il ya
d'un côté des gens qui sans le vouloir
peut-être est parfois un peu plus en le
voulant son humiliant et puis d'autres
qui se sentent humiliés de plus en plus
il ya une récupération de ce sentiment
d'humiliation et de ce ressentiment
voilà pas retardé par des politiques
habile notamment une partie de la
population qui a été humilié par son
président par emmanuel macron pendant
cinq ans si on reprend plusieurs de ces
petites phrases notamment les gaulois
réfractaires j'ai très envie d'emmerder
les non-vaccinés jusqu'au bout je suis
président je traverse la rue et je vous
en trouve du travail est ce qui est est
ce qu'on peut penser qu'il va qui va
réussir pendant les cinq prochaines
années justement à ne pas avoir ce côté
humiliant et d'ailleurs beaucoup leur
reprocher cette arrogance cette
humiliation je pense qu'il ne se rend
pas compte je pense que c'est difficile
pour lui il est trop il est trop dedans
il est trop entouré par par des gens
comme lui d'une certaine manière donc je
pense pas que ce soit volontaire chez
lui que soit délibéré je pas du tout
évidemment il voudrait il ya eu
d'ailleurs il est assez une sorte
d'empathie chez lui mais une empathie
qui elle-même est une manière de vous ne
vous l'a rapproché de plâtre kit
elle-même humiliante donc il est
important de remettre du du respect de
remettre de la considération est-ce
qu'il va y arriver je l'espère vivement
parce que je pense que c'est un élément
très important de l'évolution de notre
société tout entière ce sentiment
d'humiliation vous vous pensez que ces
humiliations elle pousse nécessairement
vers les extrêmes justement comme on
voit comme on l'a vu aux états unis je
pars à bord d'un autre homme là comme on
le voit sur les extrême gauche l'extrême
droite ça y contribue encore une fois j
rich l'humiliation créer des réactions
allumé l'association et la frustation
quelque chose rationnel il ya quelque
chose de disproportionné là les
conséquences de l'humiliation parce que
l'humiliation flée terre et donc
l'émulation ouais c'est ça ça fait moins
que nous ne nous sommes des sujets
parlant des visages et l'humiliation
voilà fait voeu rougir elle fait taire
elle du coup le l'heureux leurs
sentiments et les rancunes la rancoeur
lié à l'humiliation créer des réactions
dit beaucoup plus tard mais aussi
complètement disproportionnée donc il ya
de l'ex trader on peut être de
l'extrémisme dans dans ses réactions
disproportionnées les humiliations ont
des effets disproportionnés toujours
dans nos vies privées comme dans nos
réactions collectives les guerres etc
donc je pense qu'il faut qu'on soit
sensible à cette dimension ou fait que
voilà il ya des quelque chose de
disproportionné qui arrivent plus tard
les conséquences de l'humiliation se
font sentir souvent bien plus tard c'est
ce qui est un peu en train de se passer
d'ailleurs c'est ce que vous écrivez le
rôle de l'humiliation dans l'histoire
est plus important que celui de la
violence et notamment la russie qui a
mis souvent en avant le fait qu'elle
avait été plusieurs fois humilié
vladimir poutine s'en joue beaucoup là
dessus on peut le dire et puis il y à la
turquie aussi on en paye un peu les
conséquences aujourd'hui de 2 comme vous
le dites finalement cette humiliation et
ce côté ben en fait on attend on attend
un temps on ronge un peu son frein c'est
une idée mais c'est en train de
ressortir ma forme notamment pour la
russie oui alors bien sûr c'est de gevo
montrer c'est une manipulation poutine
manipule le sentiment d'humiliation de
du peuple russe comme verdone manipule
de sentiment d'humiliation dont le
président turc away de la tue la turquie
de la société turque qui était très
tournée vers l'europe qui peu à peu en
une sorte a été en voilà c'est s'est
senti plus en plus éloignés de l'europe
et donc s'ils retournaient vers autre
chose alors on sait pas très bien quoi
donc oui mais je pense que c'est une
manipulation et ce qui m'inquiète c'est
que de la même manière qu autrefois il y
avait un grand discours des lumières un
grand discours de l'émancipation qui en
a qui sont traversés le monde entier et
aux draps aujourd'hui il ya un grand
discours du ressentiment du ressentiment
contre l'occident notamment sur de
grands récits on va dire qui est en
train de devenir le grand récit commun
qui en train de se polariser le
politique dans beaucoup de pays et je
pense que c'est très très dangereux donc
il faut très vite réagir à cela et donc
c'est difficile de trouver la bonne
attitude face à ça mais il faut réagir à
cela qu'elle serait juste
qu'est ce que vous préconisez
difficile difficile d'abord je pense
qu'il faut que nous pensions en
intérieur dans nos sociétés des
institutions non dominante et arrêter de
faire ce déni de médiation voilà c'est à
dire c'est pas grave c'est d'ailleurs ce
n'est pas grave ça va avec une morale
libérale pour les gens qui sont forts
mais pour ceux qui qui sont qui sont
précarisées vient c'est grave et le fait
qu'il soit obligé de se taire qui ne
peuvent rien dire qu'il ne puisse rien
dire
c'est difficile donc voilà je pense
qu'il faut porter des institutions de
l'humiliante ou le moins humiliante
possible et ça c'est vraiment c'est un
exil faut apprendre c'est un
apprentissage dans les ehpad dans les
hôpitaux dans les écoles dans
toute institution d administration ca
sont peuvent être touchés par cette
institution en humiliant tout le moins
humiliante possible là il ya d'énormes
progrès à faire énorme bon et puis alors
plus largement je pense que nos sociétés
sont sont là complètement envahie par
des affects par des sentiments des
ressentiments de l'état pour une raison
aussi à cause des réseaux sociaux à
cause d'internet que ce qui est tout à
fait nouveau et qui a complètement
dérégulé les anciennes institutions on
va dire de du langage de la culture de
la parole et sait gérer qu'autrefois
les passions les affecte les plus
puissants et ai été travaillée en bord
de la scène politique parme par la
tragédie grecque autrefois par par les
religions longtemps aussi par les opéras
par le cinéma tetra il me semble que ça
cette scène à côté du politique est une
scène de deux civilisations des affects
un travail de civilisation des affects
et des passions de catharsis comme
disait aristote cette scène là elle est
en train d'être complètement dérégulé
des instituts et perdu écrasé
à cause entre des réseaux sociaux de la
désinstitutionnalisation
religieuse aussi qu'ils avaient une
fonction aussi de canalisation des
affects on va dire et la voilà la scène
politique est envahie par les sentiments
donc ça il faut réagir à cela
certainement vous on en parle et je suis
une dernière question se faire taire le
propre de l'humiliation de faire taire
on en parlait au début de cette
interview est-ce qu'on peut revenir sur
ce point quand même qui est quand même
c'est compliqué de se dire voilà quand
on aime en fait on en effet on se tait
oui c'est ça je pense que le signe de l'
humiliation c'est le cette parole
ravale notre salive orava notre parole
la part lourds entre dans la gorge du
point qu'on ne peut pas on est on est
heureux et je pense que voilà il faut de
la réaction comment comment répondre et
postée à cela c'est à la fois
réautoriser la parole c'est à dire
instituer des cartes bien la justice par
exemple institut d'abord un cadre donc
on commence par écouter ce n'est pas
tout une juge et on commence par écouter
donc on favorise au maximum la parole
que la parole puisse sortir et donner du
temps à au fait que la parole va sortir
mais ça demande du temps c'est tout un
travail justement un travail de parole
si je paie d'abord que ça sorte mans et
donc pour pourparlers est aussi un temps
pour pour se retirer pour laisser parler
les autres donc refaire la scène
essentiel de la conversation entre les
humains de la conversation site a de la
considération mutuelle du respect mutuel
de l'estimé mutuelle c'est ça que je
prends le temps de s'écouter sa demande
à s'entendre ça
c'est pas de l'argent qui moi j'ai du
temps étant c'est du temps du temps de
l'attention un peu d'attention merci
beaucoup olivier abel d'avoir été avec
nous je rappelle le titre de votre
ouvrage de l'humiliation merci encore
long ce machin on retrouve dans quelques
instants à nina masson se retrouvent
pour voir la suite de bach et direct